ONCE AGAIN, UKRAINIAN SOLDIERS
ARE IN THE CENTER OF KHERSON
CITY AFTER RUSSIAN TROOPS
RETREATED.
UKRAINIAN FORCES APPARENTLY
ENCOUNTERED LITTLE TO NO
RESISTANCE.
THAT IS ACCORDING TO SOCIAL
MEDIA IMAGES AND RESIDENTS OF
CARSON CITY.
THEY HAVE TURNED OUT IN DROVES
WELCOMING THEIR TROOPS AND
WRAPPING THEMSELVES IN
UKRAINIAN FLAGS AS YOU CAN SEE.
THE DEFENSE MINISTER SEES ITS
FORCES AND EQUIPMENT HAVE
WITHDRAWN FROM THE WEST BANK OF
THE NEW PRO RIVER AND A CURSE
ON REGION.
THAT IS CONSIDERED ONE OF THE
BIGGEST SETBACKS IN MOSCOW
SINCE THE START OF IT'S ILLEGAL
WAR IN UKRAINE.
MORE CONTEXT NOW, MARK IS HERE,
FORMER COMMANDING GENERAL OF
THE U.S. ARMY AND 7TH ARMY.
GENERAL, ALWAYS GREAT TO HAVE
YOU ON THE SHOW.
YOUR PERSPECTIVE AT THIS MOMENT,
HOW PIVOTAL IS THIS FOR UKRAINE
AND OF COURSE FOR RUSSIA TO?
>> WELL, IF I MAY, YOU
MENTIONED HOW IT WAS AN EASY
FIGHT.
IT WAS AN EASY FIGHT YESTERDAY.
BUT THE UKRAINIAN ARMY HAS BEEN
UNBELIEVABLY HEARTENED BY THIS
FIGHT WHICH THEY STARTED IN THE
COURSE ON REGION, PROBABLY
CLOSE TO 6-8 WEEKS AGO.
THEY HAVE BEEN FIGHTING ON 2
FRONTS WHICH HAVE COMPLEMENTED
EACH OTHER, BOTH IN PEIRSON BUT
ALSO IN THE NORTHERN PART OF
THE NORTHEAST PART OF THE
COUNTRY.
NEAR THE DONETSK REGION.
THEY HAVE BEEN BRILLIANT IN
TERMS OF THEIR OPERATIONAL PLAN
AND THEIR CONDUCT OF THE EVENTS
THAT HAVE LED UP TO THIS
PUSHING RUSSIAN FORCES TO THE
EASTERN BANK OF THE DNIEPER
RIVER.
IT WAS CERTAINLY A VICTORIOUS
DAY YESTERDAY AS THEY WENT INTO
THE CITY OF COURSE ON.
THERE WERE MANY PEOPLE THAT
WERE CONCERNED THAT IT MIGHT BE
A RUSE OR A TRAP BY THE RUSSIAN
FORCES.
IT WAS CERTAINLY NOT.
NOW THEY EVERY OCCUPIED THE
ENTIRE AREA OF KURSON, WHICH
MEANS THERE IS A BETTER CONTROL
OVER CLIMATE THAT WILL HARM THE
RUSSIAN EFFORTS TO FIGHT IN
MIKEL OF AND SEVERAL OF THE
PLACES.
IT IS ALSO JUST A DAMNING
DEFEAT FOR THE RUSSIAN ARMY.
IT IS NOT OVER YET.
>> THAT'S GOING TO BE MY NEXT
QUESTION, WHAT IS YOUR GREATEST
CONCERN AT THIS MOMENT, THE
RUSSIAN OFFICIALS ARE SAYING WE
HAVE TAKEN ALL OF OUR EQUIPMENT.
ALL OF OUR SOLDIERS HAVE LEFT,
THERE IS CONCERN FROM THE
UKRAINIAN SIDE THAT THERE COULD
BEAT MILITARY FORCES BUT SIMPLY
WEARING PLAIN CLOTHES SO
THEY'RE NOT RECOGNIZABLE.
THERE'S STILL THE THREAT OF
MISSILE FIRE INTO THE REGION.
WHAT IS YOUR GREATEST CONCERN
FOR UKRAINIANS, FOR CITIZENS
AND SOLDIERS?
>> MY BIGGEST CONCERN IS THAT
THERE ARE CERTAINLY RUSSIAN
FORCES LEFT ON THE WESTERN BANK
OF THE D BRO.
THEY MAY BE CAMOUFLAGING
THEMSELVES IN CIVILIAN UNIFORM.
THERE IS ALREADY BEEN SEVERAL
HUNDREDS CAPTURED THAT HAVE
BEEN PUT IN CIVILIAN UNIFORM,
SO WHAT WE ARE GOING TO SEE IS
A COMPLETION OF THE OFFENSIVE
OPERATION BY UKRAINE.
THEY'RE RAPIDLY GOING TO GO ON
THE DEFENSE, ON THAT WESTERN
BANK.
THERE WILL BE SOME RUSSIANS
THAT WOULD BE TAKEN PRISONER.
TRUTHFULLY, I THINK IT'S GONNA
BE IN THE THOUSANDS RATHER THAN
THE HUNDREDS THAT RUSSIANS LEFT
ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE
DNIEPER RIVER.
UKRAINE WILL PROVE THEMSELVES
IN TERMS OF THEIR HUMANITARIAN
TREATMENT OF THESE RUSSIAN
PRISONERS OF WAR.
BUT THEN, UKRAINIAN FORCES WILL
BE FACING, HOW DO THEY GET
ACROSS THE DNIEPER IVAR AND
CONTINUE THEIR ASSAULT ON
RUSSIAN FORCES.
THAT RIVER LOOKS LIKE A VERY
NARROW RIVER ON ANY MAP THAT
YOU'VE SEEN.
BUT THERE ARE PLACES IN THAT
RIVER OUTSIDE OF THE CAPITAL
CITY OF COURSE ON WHERE THAT IS
OVER A MILE WIDE.
IT ALMOST BECOMES AN OBVIOUS
ASSAULT.
THINK D-DAY OPERATIONS,
ESPECIALLY GIVEN FACT THE
RUSSIANS BLEW BRIDGES BEHIND
THEM.
THE QUEEN'S BLUE BRIDGES TO
PREVENT THE RUSSIANS FROM
ESCAPING, SO THERE'S NOT A
WHOLE LOT OF GREAT WAYS TO GET
ACROSS THAT RIVER FOR HUNDREDS
OF MILES.
IN SOME CASES, IT IS OVER A
MILE WIDE.
>> THERE HE QUESTIONS FOR THE
COMING HOURS AND DAYS.
THAT IS JUST A FEW OF THEM,
GENERAL, WE ALSO HEARD, I
SHOULD PUT ULTRA VIEWERS,
OFFICIALLY NOW FROM PRESIDENT
ZELENSKYY ON HIS SOCIAL MEDIA
ACCOUNT, HE SAID CARSON'S HOURS.
A HUGE MOMENT FOR HIM AS WELL
IN ADDITION TO THE PEOPLE AND
TO THE FORCES.
SPEAKING OF FORCES, IT IS
VETERANS DAY, I WANT TO THANK
YOU GENERAL, MARK, FOR YOUR
SERVICE AND FOR THOSE THAT HAVE
PROVIDED SERVICE ALL OF THE
WORLD'S.
TALK TO ME ABOUT YOUR WORK WITH
THE AMERICAN BATTLEFIELD
MONUMENTS COMMISSION.
I BELIEVE THIS IS IN TRIBUTE TO
ALL THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN SENT
ABROAD, U.S. TROOPS ABROAD.
>> YES JULIA, THE AMERICAN
COMMISSION, WE CALL IT A TMZ,
MAINTAINS 26 AMERICANS
CEMETERIES ALL OF THE WORLD
OUTSIDE OF THE UNITED STATES.
YOUR INTERNATIONAL VIEWERS ARE
PROBABLY CLOSE TO ONE OF OUR
CEMETERIES, SOMEWHERE IN EUROPE,
INDONESIA, NORTH AFRICA, IN
ASIA.
THESE ARE PLACES THAT THE
AMERICANS, WE DON'T WANT TO
OCCUPY ANY GROUND, BUT WE WOULD
ASK THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
GIVE US GROUND TO BURY OUR
DEAD.
THERE ARE OVER 150,000 U.S.
MILITARY BURIED IN THESE
FOREIGN CEMETERIES AROUND THE
WORLD.
IT IS A TESTIMONY TO THE UNITED
STATES THAT WE CARE FOR THESE
CEMETERIES WITH THE UTMOST
EFFICIENCY AND EFFECTIVENESS.
THERE ARE BEAUTIFUL PLACE TO
VISIT, THEY NOT ONLY HAVE GREAT
FOR REMEMBRANCE, BUT THEY ALSO
HAVE GREAT ARCHITECTURE, GREAT
GROUND, BUT I WOULD ASK ANY OF
YOUR LISTENERS TODAY TO PERHAPS,
IF THERE IS ONE OF THESE GUYS
NEARBY, TO VISIT AND YOU SEE
THE BEAUTY OF THE SIGHTS AND
HOW THAT UNITED STATES ROOM FOR
THE SOLDIERS.
GREAT HAVE YOU WITH US, THANK
YOU FOR ALL THE WORK YOU DO.
GENERAL, THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN.
>> ALWAYS A PLEASURE, THANK
YOU.